[Music]
and the winner is close
[Applause]
European Cinema goers and MEPS chose
Belgian director Lucas Don's film as the
winner of 2023's Lux audience award
organized by the European Parliament I
want to thank all the European audience
who went to see these films during one
of the 500 screenings and who voted it
feels incredible thank you
set in rural Belgium close portrays how
a friendship between 13 year old boys
Leo and Remy tragically unravels after
classmates questioned their relationship
a portrait of connection and loss close
draws on the director's own experience
of growing up examining how Society can
stop boys valuing their emotions or the
relationships they form with male peers
I wanted to paint this young friendship
and show the tenderness and the desire
for human Connection in there but then
also show what the loss of that or what
the questioning of that means to these
two young boys growing up did it mean s
[Music]
the awards promotes European films but
it is also about the issues that
filmmakers bring to the table about
democracy equality Justice respect
tolerance and freedom